CHRIS BROADFOOT: Hi, everyone.
We're live today from the
Sydney hangout office.
We have here today Thor to my
left, who is the product
manager for Google Maps API.
And joining us through Google+
Hangouts, Mano Marks, a
developer advocate for
Google Maps API.
So today, the topic of our
conversation will be the v2 to
v3 transition.
So it's great that we have Thor
here to talk about some
of the history of v2 and what it
means for v3 going forward.
So first of all, Thor
what does it mean to
be a product manager?
MANO MARKS: Yes, tell us a
little about yourself, Thor.
THOR MITCHELL: So a Google
product manager is essentially
someone who owns the strategy
and roadmap and overall
success of a product.
So there are normally around one
product manager for every
10 to 15 engineers that you
have working on a product.
And the job of a product
manager, a variety of things,
but in large part, it's to
shield the engineering team
from all of the other issues
that have to be resolved in
order to manage the launches
of a product and the life
cycle of a product.
So on a day to day basis, I
could be talking to the legal
team or the marketing team, or
reviewing documentation, or
doing roadmap planning, or all
manner of things, speaking at
conferences, et cetera.
So a wide variety of stuff.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Cool.
And so how long have you
been product manager
for Google Maps API?
THOR MITCHELL: For Google Maps
API, I think, two and
a half years now.
This will be my, yes, my
third Google IO coming
up as product manager.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So you
mentioned product managers
sort of develop strategy
for the product.
What's the strategy for
the Google Maps API?
THOR MITCHELL: Well I think
that for the last--
you mentioned the v2 to
the v3 transition.
For the last couple of years,
a lot of the roadmap and the
features that we've been
developing have been driven by
the need to provide the
solutions that people need in
order to move from v2 to v3.
So that has been a theme that's
sort of run underneath
a lot of what we're doing.
We obviously want developers who
are coming from v2 to feel
comfortable that v3 can offer
them what they need for their
applications.
At the same time, we do try and
take a broader perspective
on what the role of
the Maps API is.
And what is this product for
at its very basic level?
Because back in the v2
timeframe, the Maps API had a
lot in common at a 10-foot
level with
Google Maps, the website.
And as a consequence, you tended
to see that features
would launch in Google Maps,
and then would trickle down
into the API.
And we would just naturally let
that flow happen and see
how developers responded
to those features.
But I think it's important
that we keep in mind that
there is actually a fairly
important distinction between
the purpose of Google Maps,
which is about letting people
find directions, get to places,
search for businesses,
and so forth.
And the Maps API, which is
really much more about
developers, developers' data.
We are really just a platform
for data visualization that
allows you, the developer, to
put your information in a
geographical context.
And so we have a responsibility
to provide
developers with the tools they
need to better present their
data to tell their stories.
And so, I think, especially now
that we have wrapped up
the migration from v2 to v3 in
terms of ensuring that the
features from v2 that we feel
it's important to have in v3
are there, that we're going to
approach it much more on
enabling these kind of broader
visualizations.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, I mean
the use cases are quite
different from what
our developers do
and what's on Maps.
For example, Google Maps doesn't
ever show more than,
say, 10 markers at a time,
because that's what comes back
in a search response.
Whereas our developers regularly
add thousands or
tens of thousands of markers.
THOR MITCHELL: It's interesting
also that--
I would say that in the early
days of the Maps API, a lot of
what developers wanted to do
with the Maps API was informed
by what they saw us doing
on Google Maps.
So they would see a feature on
Google Maps and they would
want to be able to bring that
into their own mapping
applications.
What we're increasingly seeing
now is developers who have a
much clearer sense of the kinds
of applications they
would like to build
independently and bring to us
features that we don't have in
Google Maps that they would
like to see in the Maps API.
And we've started to see things
flowing back the other
way as well.
We've started to see Google
projects and properties
adopting services and features
of the Maps API that we've
built for development.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So there is a
Google Moderator question that
says, from Nianwei saying, "Just
saw Mano Marks's new
blog, 'Go v3, it's time to
upgrade.' So when will
maps.google.com migrate?
Why has it not after
two years?
For us, it's less reliable to
support of non-Mercator map
types in v3, and Flash-based
street view looks much
better."
THOR MITCHELL: So, it's an
interesting question.
As I mentioned, back in v2 days,
there was a lot more
commonality between the Maps API
and the Maps application.
One of the reasons why this
changed was because the Maps
API is generally used on
third-party websites.
And those third-party websites
can be accessed on web
browsers, on a wide variety
of devices.
And we cannot, in a sense,
constrain the types of devices
people use to browse the web.
And so we need to make sure that
the Maps API works well
across the full spectrum of
devices, across its full
feature set.
If you look at Google Maps,
they're in a slightly
different position.
The bulk of the mobile traffic,
for example, for
Google Maps as a service comes
from native applications on
mobile devices, rather than
loading a web-based version of
Google Maps.
And that allows them to make
technology decisions that
differ between the web
and mobile devices.
So Street View is
a great example.
Street View in Google Maps for
many years was exclusively
Flash-based.
And that works well on desktop,
but not so well on
mobile devices.
But that wasn't an issue,
because the mobile devices had
their own native Street
View communication.
You'll see that in MapsGL, of
course, Street View is no
longer Flash-based.
It's now WebGL based and part
of a broader 3D experience.
And I would expect that as the
adoption of WebGL and the
number of browsers that support
WebGL improves, you'll
see some of the same
improvements coming down into
the Maps API.
I don't currently expect that
maps.google.com itself will
switch to use the Maps API.
I think we've made a very
clear decision that it's
important for Google Maps to be
able to rapidly iterate on
features and also have the
freedom to add and remove
features and take different
technology approaches across
different browsers, which means
that its requirements in
terms of the underlying
infrastructure are somewhat
inconsistent with our needs as
not just a developer product,
but also a paid developer
product.
So we have a successful
enterprise business selling
licensing for the
Google Maps API.
And developers generally, and
particularly some of those at
large commercial developers,
they have very, very high
expectations on consistency and
stability and visibility
into the roadmap and so forth.
And there's something of a
conflict there between the
very fast-moving, agile Google
development model for our own
products and some of
the expectations
of enterprise customers.
So it's likely that Google
Maps will remain an
independent code base,
I think, for
the foreseeable future.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I guess there's
also the matter of
customizing Maps for particular
users, which isn't
possible with the API because
we serve cookie lists, so we
have no idea about which Google
account is logged in.
So there's practical differences
as well.
THOR MITCHELL: Yes.
So that's actually
very important
to some of our customers.
There are certain government
regulations, particularly
around specific classes of
sites, which means they must
not set cookies.
And so we have re-architected
the API to be totally
independent of cookies and
sessions in any way, which
obviously is good in
some respects.
It also helps has a side effect
that it helps with
performance, because,
particularly for mobile
devices on lower-bandwidth
networks, cookies can add
fairly significantly to the
payload for some of the more
lighter-weight requests we do,
such as with [INAUDIBLE].
So it's actually a positive
thing in that respect.
But it does sort of cut us
off from some of the
user-specific, end user
authenticated features that
Google Maps has [INAUDIBLE].
MANO MARKS: Hey Thor?
THOR MITCHELL: Yep?
MANO MARKS: Can you just tell
us what's the feature that's
most excited you in the last
year about the Maps API?
The feature we've been
able to release?
THOR MITCHELL: Oh, that's
a great question.
So I think I'm going to cheat
slightly and broaden the
question to the last few years,
like the time that I've
been managing the product.
There are a couple of features
that I really love.
One which I often mention--
which I realize isn't
necessarily as broadly
valuable as others--
is elevation.
The extent to which I like a
feature is often a function of
how much time I spend playing
with the demos
we write for it.
And I found elevation just
fascinating when we
implemented it.
Just being able to experiment
with the elevation profiles
across different routes.
Oops, excuse me.
And also, being able to look at
the difference between, for
example, driving routes and
walking routes across the same
city, and things like that.
And the fact that it does
underwater depth as well was a
really interesting.
So I'm a big fan of
that feature.
And people have done some really
interesting things with
it that we didn't expect, such
as figuring out the location
that they need to put mobile
phone masts, based on the
signal dissipation over
cities, based on the
elevation, and so forth.
Another feature that if any of
you follow our blog will know
I'm a huge fan of
is autocomplete.
So autocomplete, if you're not
aware of it, is a feature that
you can attach to a text field
on any web page that will give
that text field the ability to
predict places as users enter
addresses or business names.
And there are various controls
there in terms of you can
control whether we just return
addresses, or just return
businesses, or only return city
names, or only return
results in specific countries.
Essentially, every single text
field on the internet which
asks you to enter an
address in any
form needs this feature.
Without it, I can only assume
you hate your users.
And the thing is, once you've
seen that feature, and you
understand what it can do, every
time you come across a
text field that doesn't use
it, it drives you crazy.
So I'm on a crusade to have
this feature rolled out
everywhere.
Because it's one of the little
details that just makes the
web better for everybody.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Hey Tom,
welcome to the Hangout.
Have you got any questions
for Thor or any of us?
TOM HORN: No, no.
Just thought I'd come in and
listen to what you guys were
talking about.
We use the--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Tom's with
goCatch, which is a great taxi
application in, I guess,
in Australia, right?
TOM HORN: Yes.
Actually, globally.
But yeah, mostly in Australia
We've got a couple of other
centers, like Singapore
and Croatia.
But yeah, mostly Australia.
MANO MARKS: So all the
contiguous places that you can
find, right?
TOM HORN: Yeah.
So I was just saying we use
autocomplete for when the user
has to type in a suburb
for their destination.
And yeah, it's great.
Really improves the usability.
So, yeah, it's cool.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So you guys
must be using v3, then.
That's just the API, just
the auto complete API--
THOR MITCHELL: For
the Web Service.
TOM HORN: Yeah, the
Web Service.
So we use Map Kit in the iOS app
and Map View in Android.
So we do use v3 in the website
MANO MARKS: And you also
have a Windows 7 app.
What are you using for that?
TOM HORN: Yeah, that's
Bing Maps, which you
kind of have to use.
I've done a little bit of stuff
with Bing Maps on the
web as well, and it doesn't
really compare.
Which you'd expect I guess.
Well, given the majority
of Google Maps.
It's my favorite API of
all the Google APIs.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, I think
it was-- was Google Maps the
first API that we released?
THOR MITCHELL: That's
a contention point.
I think there was the Search API
that may have preceded us.
Remember SOAP?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, I do.
MANO MARKS: It definitely
preceded us.
It was being deprecated by
the time we came around.
But yeah, it was still pretty
popular with a small number of
developers when I
started in 2006.
TOM HORN: Yeah, I think I
started working on the Maps
API in 2006.
Working with the Maps
API, rather.
MANO MARKS: Shall we grab
another Moderator question?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, sure.
So what you were talking
about before sort of
leads into this one.
Actually, sort of two.
Let's do them together.
So, one more thing.
How is MapsGL--
how does that fit into Google's
geo API offering in
the future?
And that sort of leads into
"Google had a press event on
June 5 and released new features
on Google Maps, 3D,
offline, et cetera.
When will those features come
to any flavor of the API, if
ever?"
THOR MITCHELL: OK.
So the features that were
announced at the press event
on June 5, I believe, the 3D
Maps were demoed on tablet, I
believe, as part of
Google Earth.
So that's actually quite
independent right now of
Google Maps, both the desktop
product and the API.
And similarly, offline, I
think it was part of the
Android app too.
These are actually--
offline in particular is
something that does come up
fairly frequently as an
ask for the Maps API.
And it's something that, I
think, we're keeping a close
eye on the various technologies
that could use to
facilitate that.
There are some security issues
in terms of how we manage
storage of the data in such a
way that it's not easily bulk
exportable, that we would
need to address.
So it's not, unfortunately,
that simple.
But it's something that
there is definitely a
lot of demand for.
So I hope we can address
that in future.
The 3D Maps.
So essentially the technology
that was demoed on June 5,
takes the 3D environment that
you have in Earth and sort of
steps it up a level in terms of
the quality of the building
renderings, the amount
of detail.
It's a really beautiful things
to behold when you see it.
And that's being rolled out in
Earth initially for tablets.
And then my expectation will be
that it will flow through
to other products over time.
And at some point, I
hope that we can be
one of those products.
But I think it's a little
bit of a way off yet.
As far as the other question
with MapsGL.
So MapsGL is something that we,
again, have been obviously
watching closely, and we're in
close contact with that team.
And we've sort of talked about
when we would want to start
working on bringing MapsGL
into the API.
There are, again, some
challenges there are somewhat
peculiar to the API here.
One of the big difficulties that
we've had is evaluating
the devices on which we can
reliably use MapsGL and ensure
that performance is what it
needs to be, and that it is
stable and reliable enough.
And we actually did some
experiments with MapsGL in the
v3 Street View player
about a year ago.
And we did run into
some problems with
browsers at that time.
The way that maps.google.com
addresses this is that they
run a performance test within
your browser when you click
the Enable MapsGL button.
And it takes a few
seconds to run.
And once it's completed, they
decide one or the other
whether you are a MapsGL
capable browser.
And if you are, they store a
cookie that allows them to
load MapsGL from that
point onwards.
Now, as we mentioned, the Maps
API is cookie-less, which
means that we are not in a
position to do that as easily.
And we would have to run that
detection, right now, while
there's still this broad range
of performance and device
support, and graphics card
issues, and so forth.
We'd have to run that every
time, which would seriously
impact the user experience.
And so we have to--
I think what we're really
looking to do is wait for
adoption of WebGL as a
technology within browsers to
really get a little bit
more ubiquitous.
And before we feel like, not
only can we reliably use
MapsGL in a way that won't
undermine the user experience,
but also so that we can offer
features that MapsGL enables,
which developers would feel
comfortable using, knowing
that their userbase is likely
to be able to take
the benefit of that.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I guess that
goes back to the differences
in use cases between
maps.google.com and our API sites.
A lot of our sites just want to
serve maps really quickly.
And if they have that lag
before they can do that,
that's really detrimental
to them.
THOR MITCHELL: I think it's also
very important that we--
MANO MARKS: The things that I
get really excited about,
though, is MapsGL and the GMM,
the Google Maps for Mobile and
Android, and take advantage of
vector-based rendering, which
we haven't really mentioned
that here.
But it's one of the really
exciting new technologies that
we're doing.
Not just serving out map tiles,
but actually serving
out data, and then letting the
applications render it in
their clients.
I think that is going to open
up a tremendous amount of
capabilities once browsers
are capable of doing it.
And we're already seeing that on
the native apps on Android.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, I mean,
does that tie into our
strategy, do you think?
Do you think 3D is the future?
THOR MITCHELL: I think that it's
important that we focus
on what I was saying earlier
about what is
the Maps API for?
It seems like a simple
and obvious question.
But it's very easy to get swept
up in new features that
come in from Google Maps and
just assume that we have to
put them in the API as quickly
as possible, because people
will expect to see them there,
because they've seen them on
Google Maps.
And not stop and think about
what is the utility of this
feature to developers?
What has it enabled them to do
that they couldn't do before?
How do we ensure that this
feature will expand the
potential of the API to offer
developers the opportunity to
tell new stories, to visualize
data in more interesting ways,
to convey information in a way
that achieves more for them,
or that engages more
with their users?
And I think that with MapsGL,
that's a very important
consideration.
We should not add MapsGL into
the Maps AP just because, in
quotes, "3D is cool." Because
although 3D very visually
attractive, just the 3D
implementation in and of
itself, you tend to find that
people will navigate to their
home, and check it out,
and fly around a bit.
But actually making sure that
that feature can be applied to
the presentation of information
in addition to
just the imagery that we
provide, I think, is very,
very important.
And I think Mano is right.
That in a sense, without meaning
to play down the
importance of 3D, which I do
agree is an important part of
the future, and we have a
responsibility to make it
accessible, and make it easy
to use and not too
disorienting--
which is another
issue that 3D--
has for users sometimes.
But I think that in terms of
just the near term impact on
the ability of the API to offer
developers interesting
new visualization capabilities,
vectors have a
lot of promise there that I
think is the first thing that
we need to tackle.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
Because we can do something
like model---
MANO MARKS: So Tom was actually
asking a question.
Tom, do you want
to just ask it?
I know you typed it
into the chat.
TOM HORN: Yeah, that's OK.
Yeah, so just talking about 3D
and delivering vector data to
the client.
I'm wondering if there are any
plans, or if you guys can talk
about any plans to integrate
sort of a turn-by-turn mode in
the Android Map View.
Or indeed, anything you can
tell us about any plans to
refresh the Android Map View.
MANO MARKS: So just one
thing I'll note.
I think currently navigation
on Android devices can be
launched through an
intent on Android.
That's my understanding.
But yeah, The rest of your
question still stands.
I'll let Thor address that.
THOR MITCHELL: It's not
something that I'm personally
involved in directly.
So I'm not really qualified
to comment in detail.
Even on Android, the
applications that we have.
Sort of the vector based
rendering of the map is quite
a distinct implementation from
the turn-by-turn navigation.
Turn-by-turn navigation itself
is a very complex area
contractually in terms of the
rights that we can offer third
parties to offer turn-by-turn
navigation.
So my expectation is that is not
something that we would be
tackling in the immediate
future.
I think that clearly there is
some utility to having an API
around that.
But I think, coming back to
what I said earlier about
MapsGL, tackling the general
vector rendering within
Android would probably have a
broader utility initially.
So I can't comment right now on
the plans the Android team
might have.
Because the Maps API for Android
is currently part of
Android SDK.
But I have to assume that it's
something that they are
conscious of and, I would
imagine, working on.
TOM HORN: OK.
Cool.
I guess just bringing the Map
View in line with just the
Maps application on Android.
Because the Maps application
on Android is quite slick.
Whereas Map View is sort
of getting a bit tired.
It's still tile-based, and the
API itself has some problems.
So yeah, it'd be interesting
to see what's
coming up with that.
THOR MITCHELL: Yeah, I've
certainly heard some concerns
from developers about the way
that that API is structured.
I actually think that, again,
it's important that we ensure
that any changes we make to our
Maps API generally, such
as a switch from tile-based to
vector-based rendering, that
we bring more to the table than
just a different way of
showing the same map.
And also, I think we should be
conscious of the fact that
those of us who are very close
to this technology, be it
within Google or be it
developers externally, are
very conscious of these
distinctions between raster
maps and vector maps,
for example.
But end users are much, much
less conscious of that than
perhaps we realize.
And so we need to make sure,
again, that we do something
that really is compelling for
the end user, not just for
ourselves, if you like.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I guess that's
sort of similar to the
v2 to v3 transition.
On the surface of it, it's just
another way of showing
the same thing.
But obviously, there's different
design principles
around v3 and some advantages.
But what sticks out for you?
THOR MITCHELL: Well--
MANO MARKS: Actually, sorry,
somebody actually commented on
one of our posts earlier that
he smelled v4 coming.
So I thought I'd get you to
comment on that publicly.
THOR MITCHELL: Well I think that
given the amount of time
we have invested in getting v3
to the point where any v2
application can move to v3
comfortably, that's really not
a process I'd like to
kick off again.
I mean it is very refreshing,
from a product management
perspective, to be at the point
now where we really can
take a much more open-minded
view of where we can take this
product and what we
can do with it.
And really think about what
are the new and innovative
things that we can do that will
step up the capabilities
of the product without having to
worry so much about, well,
we really need to make sure
that this constituency of
developers on the v2 side are
also accommodated over here.
That having been said, it's been
working through the v3's
development we very consciously
tried to not just
bring features over from v2, but
in doing so, also augment
them and improve them and factor
in feedback that we had
from v2 developers
at the time.
So a good example of this is
the drawing tools that we
announced last year.
Maps API v2 did have the ability
to edit border lines
and draw new border lines.
When we brought it into v3, we
added the Toolbox, so there
was actually a UI component you
could use for switching in
and out of these
various modes.
V3 also has explicit support for
circles and rectangles, so
we made sure the drawing tools
would integrate cleanly there.
And we have future plans as well
to flesh those drawing
tools out more and give you more
flexibility in the way
that things are rendered
and can be edited.
So I think there's a lot of
benefits that have come with
the v2 to v3 transition in terms
of the capabilities of
the features that we
brought across.
It's not as if we've just been
copying them over as is.
But at the same time, I'm keen
that we can start work on some
newer features that perhaps
haven't been seen before and
have broad applicability.
One of the issues that we
faced with the v2 to v3
transition is, where do we draw
the line between features
that were sufficiently popular
in v2 that we should bring
them in to v3 and those that
perhaps were not that popular
in v2, and bringing them into
v3 would require a certain
amount of engineering effort,
plus ongoing maintenance?
But obviously, if we don't
bring them over, we'd
disappoint some developers.
And so figuring out where to
draw that line was kind of
challenging.
But it did mean that towards
the end of the process, we
were doing a lot of work
on relatively--
I wouldn't say niche--
but certainly features that we
were conscious had a smaller
audience than some of the other
things that we have.
And I think that it's very
important that we think about
broadly accessible and broadly
valuable features
that we can now bring.
This is also, incidentally, a
reason why we spent quite a
lot of time last year in
particular working on very,
perhaps subtle, ways in which
we could finesse the product
to make it better
for everybody.
So, for example, if you load a
Maps API v3 map on a mobile
device that has a
high-resolution screen such as
Galaxy Nexus or an iPhone 4,
we automatically now switch
into double resolution tiles
so that the imagery res is
extremely crisp.
This will also benefit
us with the new
MacBook Pro, for example.
We did work on smoothing the
transitions, particularly in
and out of obliques.
A lot of little fine details
that we thought just made the
product a better experience and
which everybody benefited
from automatically.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I guess going
back to design principles,
that's something that I've
seen a lot in v3.
So that we add these
improvements, and everyone
gets them straight away, because
we automatically
upgrade the API.
Whereas in v2, these
improvements were often hidden
behind flags that defaulted
to false.
So that's a big difference
in v3.
THOR MITCHELL: I think one of
the more significant changes
we made very early on in the
v3 development process was
deciding that we would default
to providing you with an
experience as close to that of
Google Maps as we could, and
then allow you to tailor
it from there.
Whereas in v2, you really had
to build that up yourself.
You had to add each control.
You had to determine what the
zoom behavior was on scroll
wheel zoom, and various
other things.
We noticed that the vast
majority of sites were just
reimplementing the same
code over, and
over, and over again.
And we really wanted to make
sure that, particularly if we
launch a new feature that we do
believe is broadly useful,
that developers have to do a
minimal amount of work to
benefit from that.
Because it is obviously
frustrating to us if we invest
a lot of time in something that
we think has a lot of
potential, but then we cannot
get enough awareness of that
feature out there for it to
really get broad adoption.
And v3 has done a much better
job of bringing new features
to developers easily, I think.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I think on
the v4 topic as well.
In the way that I've seen v3
designed it's designed in such
a way that it's easy to add
new features without--
keeping a consistent interface
and a sort of--
MANO MARKS: And keeping
performance.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: --comprehensive
developer
experience.
THOR MITCHELL: Yeah.
This is something we were
very, very conscious.
We talked a little bit earlier
about some of the motivations
behind v3 terms of broader
device support.
But another motivation was our
increasing awareness that we
had a lot of things that we
wanted to do with the API, a
lot of new features we
wanted to bring.
But every new feature we
brought to the API only
increased its size, only
increased the overhead
associated with using it.
So something we worked very
hard on in v3 was a very
deeply modular structure right
through the product that
allows us to load features on
demand without the developers
needing to be conscious
of that.
About a year or two into v3, we
layered on top of that an
explicit libraries model where
there are larger-scale
features, and developers
can actually
explicitly opt into them.
And that's proved to be
very, very valuable.
And I think it's something that
you'll see us continue to
exploit, to ensure that the core
of the product remains
very lightweight, and yet
we can expand the
capabilities easily.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: It's actually
a really nice example of a
large JavaScript code base.
Do you ever see us open
sourcing some of the
API or all of it?
THOR MITCHELL: I think that it's
not something that's on
the roadmap right now.
I think that it's something
that we could--
it's not inconceivable.
I think that in the past, one
of the biggest challenges we
faced is that Google in general
sources mapping data
from a very wide variety
of places.
And for a long time, we had
relationships with a couple of
large data providers
for map data.
And obviously, many of
these relationship
all over the world.
And also for local business
listings data as
well, that's another.
We have an even bigger
set of partners and
data providers there.
And obviously, a lot of these
partners that we work with,
they have certain concerns and
sensitivities about exposing
the data that they offer, and
that they've built their
business on offering through
a product that is freely
accessible globally.
And we had an obligation to them
in terms of maintaining a
relationship with them and
having continued access to
that data, which is very
important to have the coverage
and the quality that
we're known for.
We had an obligation to them
to put some protections in
place to ensure that the data
was used only in the manner in
which they expected it to be
used and that we intended it
to be used.
It wasn't available for
bulk download or
aggregation or so forth.
And some of those protections
are built into the JavaScript
themselves.
And it would be very, very
difficult for us to maintain
that degree of protection
around that
data if we open sourced.
However, for any of you who may
have been at the [? Ware ?]
Conference this year, Brian
McClendon, who's the VP of
Maps and Earth at Google, talked
about how we have been,
over the last few years, working
to build up a broader
corpus of data that we have
actually collected ourselves,
or for which we have
full rights.
And as that continues to happen,
and the corpus of data
that we have expands, I expect
that those kinds of
sensitivities will
begin to relax.
And then we can consider
looking into
options like open sourcing.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Should
we take one
more from the Moderator?
So "Currently the Google
Earth API only works
for desktop web browsers.
How will we develop dynamic
Earth apps for mobile?
Will there be a separate API,
or will we be able to reuse
the existing JavaScript
libraries, perhaps using
GWT-Earth?"
THOR MITCHELL: I think what
you're going to see--
and MapsGL is sort of the tip
of this ice berg-- is that
this longstanding separation
that has existed between Maps
and Earth will increasingly
blur.
Currently, they're treated
as two distinct brands.
Earth is the 3D globe.
Maps is the 2D Mercator
projected flat map.
And as browser technology
improves, the need for that
distinction will, I think,
decrease over time.
And I think that it's actually
quite important that from a
user perspective, we don't
need to expose
that split to users.
And we shouldn't have to expose
It should be easy for them to
seamlessly flip from a 2D to a
3D environment as they wish.
So I don't actually manage
the Earth API.
That's part of the Earth
Desktop product.
But my expectation would be
that over time, you'll see
more and more 3D features coming
up in the Maps APIs.
And a lot of the
earth imagery--
obviously we already have
satellite, and we already have
oblique view in the Maps API.
But some of the technology that
we demonstrated on June 5
flowing down through into the
mapping products and making
this distinction unnecessary.
Which means that the kind of
applications that you can
build using the Earth API right
now will be equally
possible to build using the
Maps API in the future.
That would be my hope.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I guess
we've started to
see that trend already.
The press event was a Google
Maps event as opposed to a
Google Earth event.
But it still had
Google Earth--
MANO MARKS: Just to note for
developers developing
currently, you can launch
Google Earth with
an intent on Android.
So you can send a KML file to
Google Earth and then have it
be rendered within Google Earth
on your Android device.
So I think that's an
important step.
And with network links, you
can do a certain amount of
dynamic interactions as well.
Also, you can load in Google
Maps engine layers into Google
Earth on the Android devices,
which I think is another
important distinction.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And those can
be reused on the desktop
browsers as well, right?
MANO MARKS: That's right.
It can be used in Maps API
applications, Earth API
applications, and Desktop Google
Earth, as well as WMS
servers anyway.
A whole mess of things
you can do with it.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK.
So for the USA, it's possible to
search street intersections
with queries like ampersand.
Will it be available for other
countries in the near future?
THOR MITCHELL: OK.
So the short answer to this
question for me is, I'm
afraid, I don't know.
The reason for that is that the
geocoding capabilities of
the Maps API are not something
that we manage separately or
maintain or develop
separately.
That's something that we share
common infrastructure with
Google Maps.
And there's actually a team
of engineers in Zurich in
Switzerland who manage our
geocoding infrastructure.
And they obviously have a team
of engineers there and a
product management team there
who own that roadmap and
prioritize features.
And I don't have sufficient
visibility into their roadmap
to answer that question
exactly.
What I would say is that the
goal of the geocoder,
essentially, is to answer
the queries that users
conventionally enter,
if you like.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Addresses.
THOR MITCHELL: Yes, exactly.
So any format which is kind
of the cultural norm for
verbalizing or documenting an
address in any different
country is the format that
we want to support.
And the concept of cross streets
is pretty important in
the US, and particularly where
you have your fairly common
grid-like, city layout.
As you probably may
have gathered, I'm
originally from the UK.
And cross streets are
simply not a common
concept in the UK.
And this is partly because the
road network there is a crazy
mess that, particularly in
cities like London, was laid
out hundreds of years ago.
And so there isn't really the
same kind of sense of
navigation by intersection that
you have in the U.S. And
I imagine that consequently,
the profile of address
searches that we see on Google
Maps in London, for example,
are quite different from those
that we would expect to see in
New York, or San Francisco,
or something like that.
So I can't speak specifically
to this particular feature
request in a specific country.
If there are countries where
this sort of technique, if you
like, for referring to a
location is common, and the
geocoding API does not support
that, then that's a very
reasonable feature request.
And I would encourage you to put
that on our issue tracker
and we can pass it
on to that team.
MANO MARKS: If I can just make
a comment, I think it's a
little pat on our backs here
is that we are able to
maintain this massive data
store, and also treat
addresses on an individual
country-by-country basis how
they would actually be
treated in that unit.
We're able to take advantage
of our knowledge and our
infrastructure, but also
localize the product for ways
in which people use things
like addresses
in different countries.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK.
So here's another one
from the Moderator.
It says, "There some map layers
that are documented in
the API and available in Google
Maps, but it seems to
be disabled in the API
for some countries.
For example the traffic layer
for Sao Paulo, Brazil.
Any plans to enable it?"
THOR MITCHELL: So in any
instance where that is the
case, it's almost always some
form of licensing or
contractual restriction that
prevents us from offering that
layer in the API in
that country.
We do not deliberately withhold
content from some
developers unless we have to.
The API is in some respects a
challenging concept to discuss
with the organizations that we
licence a lot of data from,
because many of them are nervous
about the consequences
of broad, free access
to their data.
And so we work very, very hard
to make organizations where we
source this data comfortable
with this.
But sometimes, we're unable to
do that, and decide that it
would be better for us to offer
that data on Google Maps
and not in the API than
not offer it at all.
In all of these cases we
always revisit this
regularly with them.
And we talk to them about ways
in which this service is being
used in other countries, ways in
which developers are making
use of the layers, point out
interesting things that have
been done with it.
You know, highlight the ways
in which this increases the
value of the services
they offer.
And encourage them to provide
us with the necessary
[? syndication ?] rights
that we need.
But sometimes, it's still
an ongoing discussion.
And so I can't give any
commitments as to when we
would enable a specific layer
in a specific country.
But just to say that every time
we have to restrict the
API in this way, it sort of
pains us, and its something
that we continue to try and
work on and improve.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And there's
a lot of code that sort of
handles all of this stuff.
So if we didn't have to deal
with that at all, it would be
quite a relief, right?
THOR MITCHELL: Yes.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Oh, and so
the other thing I might
mention is there's a spreadsheet
that mentions all
the coverage for map data,
directions, traffic, and all
these kinds of things.
I believe it's linked
in the Maps API FAQ?
THOR MITCHELL: That's correct.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So if you go
over there, you can see if
these features are available
in your country.
MANO MARKS: So there's one more
question that actually
got posted as a comment on
the office hours host.
And it says, do you think Google
Maps offline is heavy
and difficult to use on a--
it says on a call
or a smartphone.
I'm not sure what that means,
but we can address the
smartphone issue.
They're asking basically about
performance for offline on a
smartphone.
THOR MITCHELL: This is in
the native application?
MANO MARKS: It's unclear
what it's referring to.
But it says [INAUDIBLE]
when it's offline.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I guess offline
for the JavaScript API
is quite a technical
challenge.
Because the capabilities of
browsers for offline caching
is only coming into effect
relatively recently.
THOR MITCHELL: So my
understanding is that the
Android Google Maps application
has a Labs feature
that allows you to download a
certain amount of map data
within a given area
for offline use.
I am not aware of any specific
performance issues with that.
But it's not really my area
of expertise, so I may be
overlooking something.
I do know, though, that offline
capabilities in that
application were part of the
presentation that was
done on June 5.
I haven't had a chance to
evaluate the incremental
changes that have been made and
the improvements that have
been made in relation to
that announcement.
So I think that's probably just
something that we should
check out once that
launches publicly.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: It'll
be launched
soon as well, I believe.
MANO MARKS: Oh, Sorry.
Thor, I was just going to say we
probably should close this
up now, since we don't have
any more questions.
But any last thoughts
particularly as we're coming
into IO in a couple weeks.
THOR MITCHELL: I think
there's two things.
The first is we've talked
a little bit about the
JavaScript Maps API v2 and the
JavaScript Maps API v3 and
about the migration from
one to the other.
I think it's important to stress
that if you look back
at sort of how this has played
out, the Maps API v3 was
initially announced at Google
IO in 2009, and then was
graduated from Code Labs at
Google IO in 2010, at which
point the Maps API v2
was deprecated.
And deprecation essentially
is our way of informing
developers that this API is
no longer under active new
feature development, and for
setting a schedule over which
this API will be--
to give you the time to
make these migrations.
And to give you the notice that
you need before the API
is wound down.
Now, this means that the Maps
API v2 is subject to the
deprecation policy that was in
place at the time it was
deprecated, which was
a three-year policy.
And consequently, the
deprecation period for the
Maps API v2 ends around
this time next year.
And so I suppose the message I
want to get across is that if
you've been waiting,
essentially, to make that
migration to see what new
features come to v3, to wait
for the features that you need
to do that migration, that
essentially we have now, as
far as we are concerned,
completed the process of
bringing the features from v2
into v3 that we feel had a
sufficient level of adoption
of usage in v2 to merit
being included in v3.
So now is the time to make
that transition.
There's no excuse,
if you like, for
holding back any longer.
It's important to start actively
thinking about and
working on making
that transition.
And I encourage you to use Stack
Overflow and use the
forums and the other support
channels that we have to get
any help you need in making
that transition.
MANO MARKS: And our regular
office hours.
THOR MITCHELL: Absolutely,
yes.
So the second thing I would say
is Google IO is, as you
say, just around the corner.
It's a big time of
year for us.
You know we've got a lot
of exciting things
happening at IO.
I'm really looking
forward to it.
I always enjoy IO.
Just meeting developers
face-to-face, always have
fascinating conversations.
But, you know, we might have a
few things up our sleeve as
well, so I would just say
watch this space.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Will there
be a one more thing?
THOR MITCHELL: I couldn't
possibly comment.
MANO MARKS: Well thank
you, Thor.
And thank you, Chris.
Thank you, Tom.
THOR MITCHELL: No worries.
Happy to be here.